one of the notable people who does
not want an investigation into just what
on earth
happened in washington dc on january 6th
as trump supporters
broke into the capitol is fox news
propagandist
tucker carlson it's all as much of a
riot as you can imagine
we already discussed earlier in the show
that
many in the republican party including
republican leaders like
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
they don't want
the january 6th investigation to happen
and here tucker carlson praises
kevin mccarthy for opposing the
investigation recall that tucker carlson
is very much a man of the people
he's a populist he's for transparencies
for accountability
he's for all of that stuff but he
doesn't even want an investigation to
take place and here he is
uh attaboying kevin mccarthy this is not
a partisan show
we usually go after democrats sometimes
we go after republicans recently went
after a couple of times the
head republican in the house of
representatives kevin mccarthy of
california for his living arrangements
but we want to be honest above all and
when politicians do something right we
want to say so
kevin mccarthy the minority leader in
the house today did something right he
said he will not support
a commission a 911 style commission to
investigate the
insurrection of january 6. tucker is
defiantly proud
of kevin mccarthy for opposing a
commission
to investigate the january sixth
insurrection it's also hilarious to hear
tucker say
he doesn't do a partisan show i mean
that's we could do 15 minutes on that
but we won't
tucker is actually so opposed to an
investigation
that he wants to take names of all
republicans who vote in favor of it
because some do plan to the exact number
is yet unclear take a listen
the top republican on the house homeland
security committee is apparently
pushing for this 911 style commission
one anonymous house republican told the
hill that anywhere
from between 30 and 50 republicans might
join catco
in voting for this farce what are they
voting for they're voting to give nancy
pelosi chuck schumer and joe biden
more power power they do not deserve
power they did not win in november
republican voters deserve to know the
names of every congressional republican
who votes for this farce for the myth
making that is being used right now to
strip you of your constitutional rights
they should know which of the
representatives is playing along with
this poisonous hoax
so clearly tucker painting this as some
kind of partisan witch hunt
when the truth is that some republicans
are saying
they support the commission because it's
being done in a bipartisan way
not only is there bipartisan support for
the commission
not only are there bipartisan sponsors
for the commission the plan right now
would be that the commission would have
10 members democrats get to a point
five republicans get to a point five
democrats appoint the chair and
republicans appoint the vice chair
remember democrats control the house so
the closest you can get
to it being perfectly bipartisan is five
and five
democrats because they control the house
pick the chair republicans get the vice
chair and the commission
would only be able to issue subpoenas if
they're signed off on by both
the democratic chair of the commission
and the republican vice chair so
you know you couldn't even have a
situation where democrats alone
start issuing all sorts of subpoenas the
republican vice chair
would have to be on board with every
single subpoena
and yet tucker doesn't like it flames
frames it as some kind of farce because
god forbid
we should ever find out what really
happened on that day and the causes and
the explanations for why things went
down the way they did but as we said
earlier
if you were complicit you wouldn't want
to support it
and defendants accused in the january 6
trump riots have actually tried
two of them at least blaming fox news
and blaming
president donald trump neither has
worked so far
but blaming fox news tucker carlson is a
part of fox news
and it seems pretty clear that he would
be against such an investigation because
it can't possibly be good for him
i'm not saying the probe would bring
down tucker i'm not saying it would get
him to lose his show or get him charged
with a crime none of that would happen
but if you're tucker it wouldn't be good
for more attention especially in
congressional hearings
to be on the alleged role of fox news in
fomenting the riots that's very clear so
it does make sense in that way that
tucker would be opposed to it now on the
other hand
the white house does back a january 6
commission
and really one should have been formed
on january 7th maybe may of 2021 is the
best we can get at the end of the day
if they can't get republican leadership
to support it i think they probably will
but if they can't
just go ahead without republican
leadership they can find republicans who
will be on the commission because
there's enough republicans already at
least 20
who want to do the investigation some of
those republicans
will participate in good faith to try to
get some answers
and the republicans that remain on the
sidelines screaming this is a partisan
witch-hunt
i don't think they'll make much of a
difference democrats should continue to
focus on
the 70 percent of the country that sees
biden doing well on kovid
and they say yeah biden's doing well on
covet they see biden doing well on
vaccination and they say yeah the
vaccination rollout is going well
just proceed because i think you'll have
an equivalent 70
of the country that understands the
importance of doing this probe
and will support doing it if you
disagree and if you think there's
political risk to going forward without
republicans
in the leadership supporting it they've
got republicans that will be on the
commission
let me know i don't see it as a risk i
think democrats should move forward one
way or the other let me know your
thoughts
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covid rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
kovid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open
to stay afloat but covet rescue fund is
one of the few organizations working to
help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses i would implore
anyone in my audience to help covet
rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video